[Musique]
dans vos salles de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette semaine
vous retrouverez le festival play it
again c'est un festival qui a pour but
de mettre en valeur les films du
patrimoine qui ressorte chaque année
dans les salles de cinéma françaises
cette année
le grenier à sel de trappes le signer
cette année d'encours et nous as anciens
l'école au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
nous reprenons un certain nombre de
films qu'on a choisi dans un catalogue
alors évidemment on peut pas tous faire
prendre nous ici ce sera des grands
anciens fondamentaux comme la strada ou
modica mais aussi des films plus
précieux comme breaking away olivia un
film vraiment à découvrir le vieil homme
et l'enfant ou alors le grand les
grandes gueules de robert enrico nous on
a décidé de mettre en avant ce film là
cette année les grandes gueules c'est le
deuxième long métrage de robert enrico
il commence toujours sa carrière tout le
monde connaît robert enrico pour le
vieux fusil évidemment pour eau pour des
films comme cela là c'est vraiment le
tout démarrage de sa carrière et dès le
démarrage de sa carrière il va réunir
une aventure à bourvil pour faire un
film de truands un film de travail un
film qui se passe au coeur des vosges un
film d'hommes comme on en faisait
vraiment beaucoup à cette époque là où
il ya des gueules qui se retrouvent et
moi je vous retrouve propose de venir
retrouver ces gueux là au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa le 12 avril
et puis j'essaierai de vous en dire un
peu plus y aura même un petit bonus
le court métrage la rivière du hibou de
robert enrico je vous attends nombreux
le 12 avril et pendant toute la période
du festival play it again dans les
salles de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]